[Musique]
ce mercredi 9 novembre était jour de
séances plénière pour le Conseil
départemental au palais de la source
parmi les dossiers majeurs discutés dans
l'hémicycle figurait les orientations
budgétaires pour 2023 le président Cyril
Melchior et les vice-président ont tracé
à tour de rôle les grandes lignes de ces
orientations dans un contexte de
surenchérissement du coût de la vie
annoncé pour l'an prochain le
Département souhaite maintenir son haut
niveau d'action sur le territoire
notamment sur le volet social nous
allons renforcer notre politique d'aide
sociale et d'accès aux droits nous avons
un dispositif qui est la caravane
d'accès aux droits cette caravane
d'accès au droit existe depuis juin 2022
il y en a une l'année prochaine il y en
aura trois supplémentaires l'objectif
c'est d'aller vers des publics en grande
difficulté dans les quartiers isolés
ensuite il y a aussi des dalons de
quartier qui vont renforcer
ce dispositif d'aller vers et c'est
dalon de quartier ce sont des personnes
qui vont aller dans un certain nombre de
secteurs qui compléteront la caravane à
côté de cela il y a l'aide alimentaire
d'urgence ça c'est un point extrêmement
fort l'aide alimentaire d'urgence j'ai
mis l'idée qui était reprise par le
président de créer un comité de pilotage
de l'urgence alimentaire c'est quoi ce
machin c'est
un comité réunissant le département
l'État qui sont copilote les communes à
travers les CCAS l'ARS pour dire allons
mettre en commun nos moyens parce que
l'aide alimentaire d'urgence les colis
alimentaires les épiceries sociales tout
ça ça explose d'une année sur l'autre
donc le comité de pilotage est installé
et dès l'année prochaine nous aurions
nous aurons des orientations concrètes
et une mise en oeuvre opérationnelle et
on va inscrire dans le budget l'argent
pour cela la collectivité départementale
a également réaffirmé son soutien aux
acteurs de la filière agricole pays
autre axe fort de ces orientations
budgétaires 2023 le département garde la
main sur la gestion des fonds fait Ader
sur la période 2023 2027 et bien
évidemment nous allons continuer à être
la collectivité chef de fil compétente
en matière agricole et poursuivre le
développement et le soutien aux acteurs
du monde agricole on est aujourd'hui à
près de 40 millions d'euros que nous
allons investir dans l'agriculture
réunionnaise on était à moins de 20
millions il y a encore deux ans donc on
a multiplié par deux la port du
département en soutien aux acteurs du
monde agricole on avait dans notre
programme agrippé 2030 souhaité mettre
en avant la production locale et définir
véritablement qu'est-ce qui était de la
production locale avec nous avons donc
engagé une étude pour travailler sur les
différents critères qui allaient être
retenus pour effectivement cibler ces
productions donc aujourd'hui nous avons
terminé ce travail on est à
l'aboutissement et nous serons en mesure
vous présenter donc des produits 100%
réunion pour 100% réunion dans la
matière première dans les ingrédients
qu'on rajoute aussi lorsqu'on est sur de
la transformation agroalimentaire donc
c'est vraiment une cette volonté de ce
qui est une reconnaissance des produits
réunions bien sûr pour l'aménager pour
le consommateur local mais également
lorsque nous allons exporter nos
produits sur d'autres marchés notamment
les marchés européens le département
s'attachera aussi en 2023 amené encore
plus loin sa politique d'aménagement et
de développement durable du territoire
le département doit aussi être acteur
volontariste dans le champ de
l'aménagement du territoire et ce matin
nous avons renouvelé notre solidarité à
l'égard de l'ensemble des communes du
département puisque nous avons abondé un
fond pour les projets structurants du
territoire ce sont je le rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui près de 100 millions que
nous mettons à disposition des communes
pour les accompagner dans les travaux
sur leur territoire c'est aussi
d'accompagnement au titre de l'action
sociale à travers les CCAS donc là aussi
donc nous sommes volontaires et bien
évidemment deux domaines qui nous sont
chers c'est la transition écologique
puis ce que nous avons notre plan un
million d'arbres comme vous le savez
mais nous voulons faire de du
département une collectivité
éco-exemplaire à travers ce plan
negawatts donc la protection de
l'environnement la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique nous y
participons à travers ce projet à
travers ses orientations budgétaires le
département reste la collectivité des
solidarités celle qui accompagne tous
les Réunionnais dans leur quotidien mais
qui portent aussi un point d'honneur à
les inclure dans la prise de décision
comme l'illustre le lancement du budget
participatif citoyen doté d'une
enveloppe d'un million d'euros
[Musique]